Israel goes unnamed on China online map
so a lot of people noticed that two big
companies you've got Alibaba and I
believe Bou have removed Israel from
their maps that is to say this is the
CCP I I there's there's no private
sector in China that just at the same
time decides hey we're doing this thing
it looks like the Chinese Communist
party has said there is no Israel now
but what so the concern here there's
been a bunch of reporting or I should
say opinions and Analysis suggesting
this shows China is gearing up to join
this on the side of
Palestine it's possible I mean they're
saying Israel doesn't exist on their map
and I mean this is yeah listen I China
is a totalitarian state and they
Institute uh their measures without any
kind of consent uh there's no question
about it so I would I'm not surprised
that they would do this I don't
necessarily means that uh think it means
that they're going to intervene right
now Al but it's a it's a it's a definite
uh I mean look at bricks right right
China is absolutely in in partnership
with Iran and this is the this is the
fear World War II is NATO versus bricks
yeah it doesn't have to be World War III
you know look uh bricks could be
actually something that's good in the
sense that if we opened up our own trade
then we could probably be part of this
and we don't have to disband our our
affiliations and our uh our our trade
associations as we're doing right now
the the the conflicts that we're
creating and being you know and really
escalating uh are actually causing these
riffs okay because like when we sent
arms to Ukraine and I think even though
you know you said the Ukraine war is
dying down I bet you that 64 billion is
still going over there so being stolen
by somebody yeah going to find its way
into the pockets of Biden perhaps yeah
again I should say yeah I agree I mean
there's no question there's corruption
here
yeah well hopefully it doesn't become
World War III I suppose I hope not but
this is this what we're seeing now from
China
is like the first red flag where I think
we should be concerned like guys we need
this to turn down and so I'm I'm I'm now
especially with this bomb of refugee
camp I I see a lot of people I see
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton had a
statement recently where she was like
ceasefire you know Israel's being
attacked and you want to ceasefire but
Hamas is not going to give it and you
know anytime Hillary Clint says
something I'm like the opposite must be
true yeah absolutely so she comes out
and she's like we can't have a ceasefire
and I'm like maybe we need a ceasefire
and so uh we need barometers like that
out there right exactly you know it's
like U uh I was I was hanging out at at
a poker room we were talking about um
Jim Kramer and and uh cuz cuz I I can't
remember what came up something about
it's going to snow the farmers Farmers
Almanac and then uh someone mentioned
tracking stocks and I was like oh yeah
if you if you if you short short
anything kmer says you're going to be up
and there one guy go actually yeah I
think it's up for the the it's up 14% if
you bought if you shorted everything he
told you to buy you're up 14% so far for
the year tremendous tremendous but
anyway my point is Hillary Clinton says
no we can't do it we need war and I'm
kind of like all right let's figure out
this piece solution and I think I think
it's fair to say that like I I agree
Hamas attacked Israel kill civilians and
there's there's two ways to look at this
one way is Israel is going to be taking
out Hamas leaders I I I think if if
someone comes at you and attacks your
family you defend yourself and you stop
the threat the problem now is especially
with the bombing of this refugee camp
and the and the dead civilians the
collateral damage is becoming too great
and so uh I I actually I agree with AOC
I think AOC had a better answer than
Hill she said a ceasefire goes both ways
we want Hamas to stop and we want Israel
she she effectively said Hamas needs to
stop firing rockets at Israel and Israel
should go in and assassinate Hamas
leaders yeah absolutely look if if uh if
some cartel members and from Mexico came
into the United States and you know very
uh you know conspicuously killed 1400
people okay we would not bomb Mexico
okay we should use intell Ence assets to
find those people and bring them to
justice not to bomb these civilians this
this is so Israel is turning the world
against them I mean look at all the
countries that are lined up now that
would that wanted to cease fire and how
many countries across the globe are
condemning Israel right now I mean it's
almost unanimous there's only a few out
uh hold outs you know what's interesting
about this conflict is that this is we
we are at the red how do you describe it
the threshold of Western sensibilities
in in Warfare mhm if you go back 200
let's go back 300 years 300 years and I
think youall are going to know the
answer to this what would Nation a do to
the people who were conquered of that
land in in a situ like what what would
be happening if it was 300 years ago
that's a good question I I think it what
happen it's fairly obvious what I think
if it was 300 years ago yeah and we were
looking at Israel palestin as it was
today with the the the power of Israel
and what what Hamas is doing the
Israelis would go in and shove everyone
to the ocean and just Mass Purge and
kill everybody that's that's I shouldn't
say that absolutely because there are
many circumstances where countries did
not do this right but the issue is as we
advance as moral civilized people we are
like hey we don't think it's good to
just go and just kill everybody right
but during the colonial period a lot of
that and so now this is what's
interesting you've got the left claiming
that Israel are the colonizers and they
must be resisted with decolonizing
things like that and if they really were
the colonizers that these the left is
claiming they are the colonizers of you
know of your it would be merciless it
would be brutal you don't think it's
merciless and brutal right now I think
no no no no no if if if you're saying
today's brutal then we we need a new
word for how brutal it would be if this
was 300 years ago uh 300 years ago were
colonists in Africa they didn't wipe
everybody out what they did is forc
we're talking about if we 300 years ago
had something akin to Gaza and Hamas and
Israel and a bunch of people stormed
into the the borders of a settlement and
massacred 14400 people the response from
the more powerful Nation would be a
Purge of everyone well I want to qualify
something about the 1400 by the way uh
there's there's pretty good evidence
that the IDF actually killed some of
these people now I not saying this is
not hamas's fault but I'm and I'm not
exonerating Hamas but they bombed houses
that they thought were uh being were
people were being held hostage by
terrorists they bombed people on they
shot people on the street so I mean
there's a good number that were uh that
were taken out by the IDF uh and those
charred bodies that you saw in the media
those are not Poss though that is not
possible Visa V uh the uh do you have a
source I can pull up for for that that's
I've read it in five different places
Tim so I mean those are serious claims
I've not seen that say that Israel blew
up their own Villages they B they blew
up houses in which they suspected that
terrorists were holding hostages but you
need to you need to know your sources on
that one if you're uh look at middle e
uh Middle East
High we'll try and we'll try and pull
something like that up
m i don't I don't know how
uh yeah I don't
know I I that's a bold claim I mean even
even some of the IDF forces said we
didn't know what we were shooting at we
didn't we didn't know and we just
started uh shooting randomly we didn't
know what to do because they were so
disorganized now I I would admit and
it's very true that the Moss caused a
great deal of confusion and threw the
whole IDF into a complete uh quandry
they didn't know what was going on uh
and so they actually committed some acts
of violence against uh inadvertently
their own people you see this is why I
go anywhere near I think that's not true
I think what you're saying is false I
okay well I'll have to I'll have to
follow up with that right so so this is
I I take this is this is this is the
issue I take with the Israel palese
conflict is all is all the lies and
misinformation that are spread all the
time and uh but I've heard n of you
suspect I've heard I've heard I've heard
nothing about Israel bombing its own
villages we no not whole Villages I did
not say that it's houses in villages
houses I'm not say they whole
accidentally shot people on uh on the
street and and that just sounds like
lies I mean and bombed cars where the
charred bodies were found these were not
this is not possible I don't I believe
it okay let me ask you this Tim like I'm
not saying it's not possible what what
would you think is more
likely the more powerful
propaganda that uh what's being told by
the main media that uh and through uh
through coming out of Israel that this
is these are the truths or would you
think that it's more possible that the
propaganda is coming from the more
dominant forces propaganda is coming
from both however the left has a uh uh
very strong predisposition towards
manipulation and lies and deceit well
I'm not a leftist no I know and so the
the issue is you don't have to be a
leftist to fall for leftist propaganda
we we debated the hospital bombing on
this show believing and and we should
not have because Hamas made a claim and
it wasn't true and now we know it's not
true because video emerged the next day
showing the parking lot I think it's I
think it's that's kind of it's frankly
that it's it's really a mood point
because of all the civilians they have
bombed they are killing kill children
you know more children were killed in
three months or three weeks I'm sorry
three weeks this year than have been
killed in all wars uh from 2019 to now
not in each year there were like two
,000 children killed roughly 2019 20 21
22 in this three weeks they've killed
three over 3,000 just say why are we
involved because I don't know why we're
arguing the morality of two factions
fighting a war and what the
justification is for arguing at all that
either side is better or worse I I agree
listen I'm not saying there's any good
guys here okay and I did read that claim
in a few sources and I I I don't have
the exact Source on on the tip of my
tongue but let me just say this it's
really immaterial because
you're right there's we don't need to
find the good guy and exonerate one side
over the other that's that's not the
issue I just don't see that I to to you
know and that includes Israel by the way
because I think that what they're doing
if they have a superior morality to the
people that they're killing then why
haven't they shown it well I I don't
think that I don't think that there's a
situation where where the United States
is going to be able to come to a to to a
policy position that's going to make
anyone Happy Well it's not going to be
Utopia but it's got to be better than
what we've been doing I don't think that
I I don't know that I believe that now
not that I'm and again I'm not saying
that we shouldn't try or that we should
fund every time I I talk I have to put
this cave up because people are going to
start saying that oh you're just pro
Israel or whatever but that that's not
that's not what I'm saying I'm just
saying that I don't think that whatever
course of action the United States takes
is going to be sufficent or have a
substantive difference you know we have
a lot of history that we frankly are
besched with and that's going to take
that would take years to actually
dissipate and you know there's there's
not you know we can't take back the fact
of what we did in Iraq no that that's
that you're you're right but I mean the
the the tumultuous Middle East goes back
to the birth of our country you know the
very the reason we have the Marine Corps
is because of the barbery Pirates off
the coast of North Africa that area
is a show and it's always been an
absolute mess so the United States can
we can do our best to stay out of the
the political issues and and tribal
Warfare that happens in the Middle East
but I I don't know that whatever course
of action we take it doesn't matter
about like as as much as this is not
condoning the Iraq War but the Iraq war
is not why the people in the Middle East
you know hate us it's it's that's not
the reason not the reason but it's one
it's not the re it's not that we built
bases in Saudi Arabia it's not that
Israel exists it's been that way forever
well I mean according to Iraq that they
attacked Kuwait the first time because
of our bases in in Kuwait so I mean
there is because the bases in the in in
Kuwait and that was the reason for 9/11
as well is because the bases in in the
Holy they looked at it like the United
States was conquering right uh you know
a part of the Saudi Arabia and I I
understand that our footprint is too
broad that's the problem so yeah it'll
take a while to wash off the the the the
dirt that we've been involved in but you
know there's no time like the president
to start I again I'm I'm not arguing
that we shouldn't what I'm saying is
even if we take I think that even if we
take the course of action that you
believe is the or that Libertarians
believe is right and I support not all
Libertarians but I do but and and I
support that course of action I believe
that that is a that would be a good
policy but I don't think that that fixes
the problem I think that as many I think
it's naive to think that that that will
solve problems eventually I think that
it's it's going to be a mess over there
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at Tim cast.com
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time